he's no I ain't history but I remember
the light don't remember what and I'm
here to talk to you about the greatest
movie I've ever seen in my life
and I don't say that very often the
neverending story
now I won't exactly ruin the movie for
you so I'll just tell you everything
that happens there's this kid who finds
a book in the book is about the fantasy
leg it is a giant rock monster and a
bunch of other little presents and what
monster is like we're in trouble I'm
being chased in the other guys are like
but what nothing oh that's nothing to
worry them no it is something to worry
about what is nothing I thought you said
with something it is something that
something is nothing nothing nothing so
there's nothing to worry about
yes but what's up first that's what I
want to know so they go to this castle
where they get this hero who's a little
boy in their life what's your name a
train gesundheit so he rides on his
horse artex all around this fantasy
world and he just stuck in the swamp
ascended and the trail is like I'm the
very center takes are you you are tagged
to be saved by a dragon who kind of
looks like a giant Empire and he's led
what's your name a tree could you take
two yes to face the challenge of the
laser zapping Nicky ladies
so this guy is like only the true poet
can pass through and the others get
turned breaking heat so a trio is like I
am true heart I will pass through to the
other crap take that Lisa's happy Nicky
ladies that's hot so he comes across
some nun Laser zapping naked lady's in
there like who are you at Rheem cans
intake so they tell you that in order to
say the world he has to give the
Emperor's a new name okay then he comes
across this evil one thing that's
working for the nothing and he's like I
have to kill somebody
oh that's for you Constantine day so he
kills the evil one thing at first it's
like hurry and then it's like we had the
wounds in it but they find the Magic
Castle and they go inside to talk to the
Emperor is reflection they don't gather
and she's like the boy meeting the book
is to give me a new name as a boy
book is like versus like grows up okay
to the boy goes to get out the emperor's
new name and he's like Indian versus
like what was that it was my mother's
name boy your mother the trans minion
Devin so the boy seize the day as he
writes the giant ape and who swoops down
and eat small children hurry hurry so
you can tell like really really like
this movie there's just one problem
though it says that the reigning time is
92 minutes that's bullcrap the running
time should be never-ending that's just
false advertising Kirstie Alley in the
burning story even though it friggin
ended I wish it never ended because the
longer it went the longer I can stay in
Salem or more building can you some lamb
you with a Waterville are building right
now I'm living in a can of tuna I don't
want my plates and residents to be a can
of tuna
no can you spinach that would be
different this is just Arriba I remember
either way don't give away is a cilium
each edge you can change come on have a
guy Amelia come on change april fools
Cruzeiro can she help me move to a can
of spinach